so what do you think it is today is it
even
i don't weaponry like explosives that's
this so this is what i've been talking
about when it comes to this concept of
like civil war and all that
is no it's it's it's mind control it is
absolute mind control
when when uh the easiest way to
understand that we are all being mind
control
mind control is first when people in
okay let me let me tell you something i
talk to people about persuasion
techniques i used to do non-profit
fundraising
literally walking up to strangers on the
street and being like i need you to give
me 100
right now and i could make people sign
over credit cards it's really amazing
when you consider there's a job
where someone's standing in the street
greets a stranger
and then says give me your credit card
information right now and you will get
nothing in return
that is the fundraiser's job when they
do the street canvassing what you're
doing is you're selling them an idea so
it takes real persuasion and skills
i always tell people you are not
invincible no one is
everyone can be controlled and
manipulated and you know what everyone
says
not me so here's what i do whenever i
explain to people
i'll say i can make you say something
and they'll say no you can't i can make
you say something you don't even realize
it
i can make you say yeah but not me wanna
bet
and they'll be like what i'm not i won't
say that and then i'll wait a minute or
two and then i'll be like let me explain
to you how mind control manipulation
works
i'll break down the basics of it and
they'll go yeah but
not me and i'll go you owe me 10 bucks i
made you say that
it's not so much that i made you but i
knew the sequence of events to get you
to say it
considering that i always tell people if
mind control
mental manipulation wasn't a thing
coca-cola would not be spending billions
of dollars on these commercials and
billboards and research
you would not have social media
companies selling your data to predict
your behavior
they want to know what makes you do
things and why so they can exploit you
for resources
it sounds a bit nefarious you can break
it down to the guy at coke wants to make
10 more dollars
and he's going to do whatever he can to
figure out how to get you to buy another
coke
it's called marketing but now you have
this era
where it's been so incredibly refined
that big tech companies they know what
what you think they know why you're
thinking it they know what they want you
to think
and they are absolutely stripping away
the individuality
through these networks what's happening
now is whether intentionally or not
we cannot go outside in big cities for
the most part
mostly in blue areas can't go to bars
can't go to restaurants gotta wear a
mask
hard to talk when you're wearing a mask
hard to read someone's lips a lot of
people don't realize this but when we
talk to each other we are reading lips
so there's a bunch of research showing
how you can change the sound
but the lips will still make people hear
a different word when you're in a bar
and someone's talking you will hear the
sound and the movements of their mouth
and go i know what they're saying
take away the image you know take away
the ability to see their mouth and now
you're going to be more confused
very very difficult to communicate ideas
during this lockdown
then you go on social media and they say
you can't talk about this this this this
or this you can't say that donald trump
speech
gone outright right side broadcasting
network you're banned for two weeks for
even showing the president saying it
ideas are being restricted this is the
greatest weapon
we've ever seen imagine if in during the
civil war
a guy showed up to the confederate and
said i will win you this war without you
firing a single shot
will you buy this weapon and say what is
it and they would say the printing press
or the ability to spread propaganda in a
guaranteed manner
what if i told you that the people of
the north could only
read what we made them read we could
we could tell them that we could have
them vote for insane things that would
destroy their own country
we can have them vote for sending you
know for politicians that would harm
them
we can trick them into believing they're
so that our soldiers are in different
areas
you control what they think and you need
not fire a single shot you could march
into dc
and never have to fight anyone and they
will smile and celebrate as you do it
that's what's happening with big tech
and all this manipulation
who needs a nuclear bomb what's that
going to do scare and harm people
in today's day and age why bother
forcing someone
through violence when you can simply
tell them to do it and they will if you
look at the ccp
what they're doing to the uyghurs like
that's violent like why not be
violent if you can as i guess that's up
to these psychopaths is what they're
thinking and i've listened to putin talk
about weapons of war
and said that all this defense against
intercontinental ballistic missiles has
become null now you can fire
late like orbital strike from and he was
very vague about what kind of weapons
from god yeah he was like they can't
stop it the united states can't stop
you guys know what rods you know rods
from god are i heard about
tungsten hypothetical tungsten rods
floating in orbit that they just release
and then gravity pulls it down and
interesting i didn't know it was that
yep i thought it had more to do with
satellites but um
well yeah satellite would be holding a
tungsten rod and just released okay and
then released it all the time
i'm also concerned with drone dogs like
we were talking about drone dogs before
like
drone weapons you know like nuclear mis
nuclear bombs attached to a drone
won't let's get into that but i i do
want to talk a little bit more about
strass how and then i do want to talk
about the police state
the the the the cyber dogs they got in
new york
uh so this the stras howe generational
theory
when does it start is that was there
something before the revolutionary war
or are they just basically saying hey we
had a revolution
80 years later civil war 80 years eight
years later world war ii probably
another thing's going to happen
or they or was there something we just
don't talk about before that
yeah you know so in the book they're not
really clear the earliest
uh crisis period that i think they
mentioned is the glorious revolution
though they do go back into roman
history and they say that the term
ceculum means a long life because by the
way
you know anyone who's entering this
crisis period um
wasn't around in the last crisis so uh
it's usually people
are dead they're they're not around
enough to even know what the pattern
means so history repeating itself they
don't
quite get it but it goes back to the
glorious revolution
like i said in um in england before that
they don't really get
much into this period so it seems like
they're talking anglo-saxon american
history but
they do mention and this is where my
understanding breaks down is other
countries going through their own cycles
and they said if two countries this was
also part of
chapter six if anyone wants to go in
there and check it out of the fourth
turning
if two countries reach their crisis
period at the same exact time
usually that's when it uh it
will definitely end in war or it's a lot
more likely to end in war if two periods
are
two major powers specifically are in
crisis at the same time
but it seems like well we're facing two
potential threats china
but also civil war and so if you're if
we look internally
we have two tribal factions you have the
populist right and then you have the
establishment the populist left
tends to support the establishment tends
to well they'll rag on joe biden but
they'll throw their weight behind them
so
you know you may as well have that then
you have disaffected moderate
individuals like me
i throw my weight behind trump for
instance to a certain degree voted for
the guy
supported him in some endeavors but i
i'm fairly critical just like the
populist after critical the democrats
but
also throw their weight behind them it
seems like because of
facebook's dominance twitter the
internal war being fought right now does
include
low-tier violence and mass protests and
riots as well as
many you know these individuals who
stormed the capital so there is violence
but it seems like the bigger fight is
just the fact that lines of
communication are completely controlled
right now by
the left tribe which would say to me
that by 2028
the the populist right tribe will be
non-existent if that's the end
of the of the you know major climax if
they're talking about insurrection
and violence and talk of secession it
sounds like we are entering another
civil war period
texas is already they got they got
legislation pushed forward that will
allow the state
to vote for secession and the texas gop
is supporting the bill
i support the idea that people should be
allowed to vote for things they want
will they actually be able to pull it
off i don't know
but if joe biden is pushing this very
very heavy gun control stuff
that's the easiest way to look at how
joe biden's policy demands
do not fly at all with red states
and and some blue states to a certain
degree what i mean by this is
the gun control measures he proposed he
proposes are very good
for blue blue cities the people who who
live there they want them
they like them they don't want guns and
they live in really close proximity with
cops everywhere so for them
they get it but joe biden wants to have
this gun control
even in red states nationwide so what's
happening now is
the ideological divide between how
someone wants to live is so
they're so diametrically opposed that
when joe biden is like i'm gonna pass
laws that benefit cities
you know to help with everybody else you
end up with
talk of right now we have many counties
who want to secede from those states to
go to red states
but sooner or later we're going to see
more than just murmurs
we're in 2021 if the climax is supposed
to be
or we're in the climax but if the end is
supposed to be 2028
i don't think it's fair to call the
climax right now because if this is
going to keep escalating until it
finally
goes off the cliff and just stops and
then restarts and the climax is going to
be 2027 december 31st i'll tell you
i think september 11th was the inciting
incident and we're in year 20 right now
i don't know about airplanes i mean the
financial crisis was was way
way way worse now we can talk in terms
of
uh global damage and societal change
the economic collapse it sparked occupy
wall street
it created years of mass protests it led
to the rise of people like trump and
bernie sanders
so the reason we get someone like trump
a lot of the people who supported trump
were occupy supporters
now i get it 911 was all was a
nightmarish tragedy
and the patriot act which is basically
the martial law part of this
yeah but the patriot act was if if
anything
people didn't care they cared sure sure
some activists cared but for the most
part it didn't impact regular people
the mortgage-backed security crisis the
financial crisis everything that
followed
brought people to zero and people were
were
desperate they were angry and what did
they see the banks get bailed out
so what happens then is you go to occupy
wall street you had
left and right basically screaming at
the establishment
well try as they might and they
succeeded they kept the left and the
right divided on this issue
when the young leftists came into
zuccotti park they drove away the
libertarian and the conservative ideas
that were there
and dominated with far left populist
ideas you then move forward and you have
the rise of bernie sanders
the establishment clearly did not want
bernie sanders to have any power
but they were they seemed to have been
taken by surprise
at the rise of this left populist
movement and hillary was
furious and bernie was rivaling her she
was supposed to win bernie was supposed
to get close they cheated
they were submitting for you know one
example is they gave the questions to
hillary so she would know
what they were gonna ask her and could
prepare beforehand the whole thing
seemed to be dirty
and bernie sanders supporters believed
it but you also got many people who saw
the populist message from trump
the interesting thing about the
2015-2016 presidential cycle
was that bernie sanders and donald trump
had many of the same core policies
bernie sanders is on record speaking
with vox.com saying open borders is a
koch brothers right wing proposal
you had people i met i met three guys in
anaheim at a trump rally who said
they were originally bernie sanders
supporters they flipped for trump when
hillary won why
they said bernie sanders is a guy whose
job has been has been to be a politician
and he's talking about these free trade
agreements he's talking about union
workers i like these ideas
he's a little too far left for me but he
seems genuine and way better than the
establishment when
hillary clinton basically took it from
bernie they said
well the only other guy talking about
these free trade agreements and bringing
our jobs back is trump
so they flip for trump two different
elements of the populist revolt
which started primarily because of the
economic collapse
and how it destroyed the lives of many
people now you have two things to
consider for one boomers lives were
destroyed and they got angry
so they said bernie or trump you then
had millennials who are now entering a
job market
competing with boomers for entry-level
jobs now you have gen z
who literally entered the market after
that where there were no jobs
and so they're all basically becoming
socialists or i should say
they're very socialistic albeit there is
a slight
uh push towards some conservatism but
it's no surprise
that you see so many socialist youth
when they're like
by the time i was old enough to get a
job what scraps were left were taken up
by millennials the millennials are like
i did everything i was told to
and then when i tried to get a job all i
could go was entry-level garbage i could
barely pass my student loans
the system isn't working when you take a
look at the m1 money stock what do you
see
up until 2008 there's a slow and steady
increase
at 2008 it sharply increases and then
here
in 2021 i'm sorry in 2020 it shoots
straight up
now they say it's because they change
the reporting metric for it
however before they change the reporting
metric the spike had already begun
so if anything it seems like they
changed the reporting metric because
they needed to mask it to some capacity
so in my view 2008 was this major
economic catalyst which sparked this
populist uprising
which leads to donald trump which leads
to now claims of democrats saying
insurrection the culture war and the
clashes and everything around it are all
merging into one
and it's coming to a point where we just
had federal charges for antifa dropped
in portland
yet they're going after some befuddled
granny who walked
into the capitol building when the cops
opened the door for her republicans and
people in the tribal right can see that
there's a double standard and they're
being treated like second-class citizens
that antifa for over a year can burn
down entire cities
and the vice president before now at the
vice president
literally can fundraise on their behalf
and it is accepted
but you get a video of the cops opening
the door at the capitol and saying
well i don't agree with it but i agree
with you right to protest and welcoming
them all in
and these people walking smiling taking
selfies respecting the velvet ropes
smiling and taking pictures with cops
and now these people are facing serious
charges and they're being called
insurrectionists
and lawyers won't even represent them
now we're seeing the wave of censorship
that's escalating
the conflict has only gotten worse both
sides are ready to just slam into each
other and i think
it's going to get bad i think the the
2008 thing
makes a little bit more sense mainly
because there's something about the
the winter crisis period that they
mentioned
so like instead of just looking at the
external like what are what are the
events and
and things like that take a look at
people's behavior because they they do
say
sparks inciting events if it happens
in a different turning like in the in
the spring or the summer or the fall
we behave differently and so in 2001
you didn't see as many people amassing
so they say in a high
period which is right after a crisis the
number one thing that sparks
uh create a synergy it's actually
synergy
um in an awakening which
you go back and look at the hippie
generation it's argument that's the
number one thing sparks
uh do and then during an unraveling it's
anxiety
but during a winter period it's action
and you see a lot more action come the
2008 like you know from that
entering to um uh the occupy
and then everything from there people
and and even just the ease of
social media getting together bringing
your ideas together it seems like people
are a lot more action oriented
and they do say that you know the new
presidents that come in during this
period
will will have a you know no bs like
straight to the point
let's get down to business kind of like
action orientation
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel tim youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you